une réaction après cet attentat la
consternation comme comme beaucoup de
gens avec désolation la tristesse de
voir encore des victimes en france la
ville de nice qui est à nouveau touché
après l'attentât un terrible du 14
juillet 2016
et puis c'est une véritable désolation
pour notre démocratie on ne peut pas
avoir un état de droit une démocratie
qui fonctionne normalement avec autant
d' attentats depuis celui de mai rakkas
à tous les débats finissent par
apparaître à une île et par celui ci il
faut vraiment vraiment définitivement
éradiqué l'islam islam politique les
samis sme en france on en parlait à
l'instant avec notre invité est faire de
le dire une source proche du dossier
l'assaillant présumé des faits sur un
tunisien de 21 ans qui est venue par
ligne de lampedusa est ce que ça ne va
pas relancer le débat sur l'immigration
qui actuellement si je peux le dire bien
violents en france et en europe
oui c'est jean rossi mais le problème
n'est pas tant la et votre île et il est
là partiellement c'est là qu'il faut
faire un contrôle beaucoup plus sérieux
de dt des immigrés venant en france dès
évidemment mais le problème vos
prédécesseurs le disais c'est que il
trophée beaucoup de nouvelles lois
antiterroristes à chaque fois qu'il ya
un attentat mais on ne s'occupe pas des
mesures principales qui devrait être
prise pour pour lutter contre le
terrorisme et l'islamisme politique et
ces mesures sont comme le dit
l'intervenant précédent renforcer le
renseignement humain c'est impératif
la deuxième c'est de renforcer la
justice car c'est le renseignement et la
justice antiterroriste qui permettent de
mettre un arrêt et à mal les réseaux
terroristes et a minima il faudrait
créer un deuxième parquet antiterroriste
et pas un seul comme c'est le cas
actuellement ça nous éviterait de perdre
les compétences de juger mérite
connaissant parfaitement les réseaux
djihadistes comme le juge trévidic qui
ne peut pas mettre en fonction plus de
dix ans et puis enfin troisième point
est que n'aborde pas réellement
emmanuel macron ni ce gouvernement c'est
les relations que nous avons est qu'à
une partie de la classe politique
française avec ceux qui nourrissent
idéologiquement et financièrement le
terrorisme à savoir certains pays du
golfe comme le qatar et l'arabie
saoudite après ce genre d'attentât il
faut exiger de leur part immédiatement
qu'ils nous fournissent des listes de
potentiels terroristes
il faut jusqu'à et si nécessaire coupez
d'en avoir en france coupé les réseaux
le zoo de jazeera il doit coopérer avec
nous définitivement pour éradiquer ces
islamistes
alors c'est l'avis de certains que le
gouvernement français aurait privilégié
l'intérêt économique à l'intérêt
national c'est un peu ce qu'il a fait en
ayant des partenariats avec l'arabie
saoudite du qatar comme vous venez de
citer
oui mais ce n'est pas que ce
gouvernement c'est les gouvernements
précédents mais je prends un exemple
avec le ch et manuel valls qui est très
critiquée fort légitimement sur l'islam
politique en france mais c'est lui qui
assume et en 2016
la relation stratégique avec l'arabie
saoudite c'est également lui qui avec
françois hollande a envoyé des armes aux
djihadistes indirectement mais de facto
on sait très bien et c'est pour ça qu'il
n'y a pas d' enquête parlementaire sur
le devenir des armes françaises qui ont
été envoyés en syrie pendant le conflit
et dont une bonne partie sont retrouvés
dans les mains des jihadistes donc oui
visiblement certains privilégient les
les les accords économiques avec ces
pays là mais ils ont eux aussi avec nous
et de toute façon la première le premier
devoir d'un gouvernement c'est d'assurer
la sécurité dans son pays
or on ne peut pas continuer à avoir des
relations avec ce genre de pays si il
continue à rire le terrorisme
international
et puis je me rappelle qu'une partie de
ces la coopération économiques que nous
avons avec ces piles à consiste à
rentrer à vendre des armes qui servent
actuellement et qui ont servi dans une
guerre terrible qui est celle du yémen
et dont personne ne parle et qui
elle-même produira son lot de réfugiés
et de
candidat au terrorisme alors vous
parliez à d'islam politique actuellement
en france et système politique qui en
fait l'apologie armés qui ont fait
l'apologie mais les islamistes eux mêmes
si le problème d'un état de droit et
démocratique
nous avons toute une série
d'associations et je pense en
particulier au ccf et baraka city et je
salue pour le coup le gouvernement de
mener des démarches de dissolution
envers ces organisations mais il y en a
d'autres qui profitent de l'état de
droit qui profitent des dispositions que
qui permettent en france s'exprime et
d'avoir un avis pour lutter contre ce
même cette même liberté d'expression et
contre l'état de droit est bien pour ces
gens là il faut appliquer ce que ça
juste disait c'est à dire pas de liberté
pour les ennemis de la liberté il doit
me dise où doivent être interdits ils
doivent être traqués et chassé de france
on peut étonner
en tant que français je suis assez
étonné que l'on puisse aussi rapidement
expulsé de france
une famille de bosniaques qui avait
tendu la tête de leur fille parce que
sortait avec avec un garçon chrétiens
serbe
ça s'est fait assez rapidement comment
ça se fait que toute une série d' imam
financé par étrangers qui font des
prêtres antirépublicain et ne violent
antisémites ne sont pas ne sont pas
exclues la même manière on doit frapper
très fort et le gouvernement de le faire
immédiatement
heureusement castex a appelé à tout à
l'heure à l'unité et à la cohésion suite
à l'attaqué
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
possible au vu du climat actuel en
france mais sur ces questions à ces
impératifs et la cohésion et l'unité
avec avec entre autres les musulmans
puisque certains n'ont pas manqué de
mettre tous les musulmans dans le même
paquet alors ça serait une catastrophe
et c'est ce que disent les terroristes
c'est ce que visent les islamistes c'est
ce que vise les 100 politique ccc créer
des devis
il faut être absolument radicales sans
aucune pitié avec les saints politique
est rappelé que la plus grande partie
les musulmans de france sont lake
beaucoup venant d'algérie se sont
réfugiés en france parce qu'ils ont subi
l'islam politique pendant les années 90
nous accueillons également des clubs par
exemple qu'elles sont musulmans et qui
ont été le fer de lance en syrie contre
des jld
donc voilà surtout ne pas faire
d'amalgamé et pour ne pas faire
d'amalgamé il faut être sans pitié que
l'islam politique est également il faut
être
il faut être beaucoup plus dur avec ceux
qui ne supportent pas la liberté
d'expression dans notre pays peut-être
que la france n'est pas un départ n'est
pas le pays où doivent y est fort si la
liberté religieuse la la la la foi sont
plus importantes que les lois et les
valeurs de la république
peut-être devrait-il aller vivre
ailleurs il ya des pays où c'est comme
ça comme les etats-unis ou la
grande-bretagne où on voit que
visiblement ils ne comprennent pas le
concept français de laïcité vice
présidents de républiques souveraines
vous êtes toujours avec nous en direct
sur rt fonsorbes au cou par la presse
est important du renforcement de la
sécurité aux abords des lieux de culte
ou par exemple des lycées des collèges
des écoles primaires qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
écoutez je suis très étonné par la
mesure qui a proposé
emmanuel macron de renforcer le
dispositif sentinelles je crains que ce
ne soit plutôt une décision politique je
vous ai dit ceux qui s'intéressent à ces
questions ça fort bien que la manière de
lutter contre le terrorisme était une
manière pro active c'est à dire qu'il
faut renforcer le renseignement et la
justice terroriste mais c'est une
défense passive dont l'efficacité est
très médiocre comme l'a montré un
rapport parlementaire qui avait déjà été
fait à l'époque de la présidence de
monsieur françois hollande donc que
monsieur emmanuel macron doit évidemment
connaître qui canalise est qu'il
analysait qui montrait que la lettre
très peu d'efficacité et qu'elle avait
pour effet des cuisines
nos militaires qui ne sont qu ils ne
sont pas là pour faire des opérations de
police
c'est la gendarmerie et la police
nationales qui doivent le faire qu'ils
doivent avoir des effectifs renforcés et
qui n'ont pas les moyens entraînement ni
les armes adapté à la lutte anti
terroriste sur le territoire français et
que souvent comme on l'a vu au moins
deux fois il me semble ils ont été
prises à partie eux mêmes étaient cible
de deux terroristes donc cette mesure
est assez est assez est assez étonnante
et puis vous imaginez le nombre
d'églises qu'il est en france et pas que
des églises
il y à des synagogues il ya des mosquées
il ya des temples car les terroristes
dans certains groupes s'attaquent
également à des à des mosquées sur le
second étrange mais c'est le cas c'est
déjà arrivé avec la mosquée de drancy
puisque pour les extrémistes était trop
était trop libérale bon et bien protégé
tout les tous les lieux de culte est
quasiment impossible par contre faire
quitter le territoire national
les fichiers s c'est quelque chose qui
est possible et qu'ils devaient être
faits notamment comme l'annoncé gérald
darmanin le sens qu'ils vont être 231
fischer est de nationalité étrangère est
je suis fait plus de 4200 voilà être
expulsés de france alors le
renseignement vous en avez parlé c'est
une notion qui est beaucoup revenus au
cours de cette édition avec nos
différents invités à quel point c'est
important d'avoir un renseignement
efficace dans la lutte contre les
terroristes
est ce que c'est le cas en france c'est
fondamental
c'était déjà dans l'indre dessous l'art
de la guerre le principal le principal
le sujet des et il sait leur
enseignement être informés quand on a
informées on sait comment agir ou
frappés et comment se défendre c'est
l'état c'est un truisme et qui s'est
vérifié dans toutes les formes de guerre
que l'humanité a pu traverser et donc
le renseignement est fondamentale vous
avez deux types de renseignements vous
avez leur entraînement
maintenant électronique qui est qu'est
la faveur des états unis qui
malheureusement de plus en plus s'impose
à nous car nous sommes sur le plan
militaire en ce moment très suiviste des
états unis et mais c'est un
renseignement qui a montré largement
sont d'une efficacité
ce qui est très efficace et la france
avec une grande efficacité et toujours
les services de renseignement font un
gros travail
il ya quand même de nombreux attentats
qui sont des jouets et en général c'est
parce que ceux de l'ong des enquêtes
longues sont menées par le renseignement
et la justice antiterroriste
donc quand une fois c'est fondamental
des efforts doivent être considérables
doivent être mis dessus des moyens je
vous disais l'ouverture d'un second
parquet antiterroriste justement au
niveau du renseignement renseignement
extérieur est ce que il ya une
coopération internationale dans cette
lutte contre le terrorisme qui est assez
efficace
bien évidemment les occassions
international malheureusement elle et
elle n'est pas complète
il ne se fait pas avec l'ensemble des
pays mais il faudrait un peu mettre de
côté certains conflits que nous pouvons
avoir par ailleurs avec avec d'autres
pays
je pense en particulier à la russie et à
renouer des liens de coopération
beaucoup plus fort sur les questions de
terrorisme en algérie quand même même à
l'époque de la guerre en syrie alors que
nous étions en conflit avec le régime de
monsieur assad
nous avions su élever notre présence sur
le territoire syrien
mais les allemands et que avait maintenu
une antenne du renseignement allemand ce
n'était pas par alliance avec monsieur
assad bien évidemment il était contre
lui mais c'était pour maintenir une
coopération minimum afin d'avoir des
renseignements qui permettent et qui ont
permis d'éviter des attentats
donc oui la coopération est fondamentale
la formation permet de prévoir qui
permet d'éviter des catastrophes comme
comme celle que nous connaissons trop
souvent 7 buts du terrorisme en semer la
terreur frapper n'importe où n'importe
quand n'importe comment n'importe quel
endroit est ce que c'est vraiment
possible de prévenir ce genre d'actes
mais ce n'est pour lesquels vous avez
des opérations qui sont montés par des
groupes terroristes très coordonnée avec
des opérations de logistique par lourdes
traite ou parfois extrêmement lourdes on
pense aux attentats contre le world
trade center en 2001
mais alors le bataclan et puis vous avez
ce que l'on appelle les loups solitaires
mais il faut bien comprendre une facette
cette expression un petit peu un peu
galvaudé les loups solitaires cercle
n'ont pas de l'officier traitant n'ont
pas de raisons derrière eux n'ont pas de
logistique qui désarment et décide
d'entrer en action quand ils décident
eux-mêmes d'entrer en action
mais il lui lille fleurissent sur un
terreau et ce terreau ce et c est bien c
c'est un terreau idéologique c'est un
terreau aussi qui leur permet de de
vivre dans certains dans certaines zones
dans des quartiers où ils ne sont pas
gênés ou petit à petit et peuvent se
radicaliser voilà donc pour lutter
contre le terrorisme bien évidemment on
peut pas prévenir les actes d d tous les
loups solitaires a fortiori s'ils sont
si son faisceau psychiquement déranger
ce qui n'est pas le cas tous mais c'est
en cassant les le terreau sur lequel il
se radicalise et donc il est absolument
impératif de je répète de chasse et de
france les étrangers fichier s aura
d'égalisation islamistes fermer les
mosquées radicaliser chasser les imams
formés à l'étranger
c'est en particulier l'arabie saoudite
et au qatar qui véhiculent des messages
de haine
et plus et sur les sites saborder les
sites jihadistes
mais bon ce qui se fait ce que je fais
déjà oui c'est ce qui a été fait on en à
peine 1 des solutions de bara kasse
lithiques du ccf et puis fermeture en
tout cas penser aux débuts voilà de la
mosquée de pantin qui a été identifié
qu'un une mosquée radicale monsieur
puisse modric à ce que vous vous estimez
qu'à la france est plus ciblé que
d'autres pays voisins
les pays voisins ont subi énorme en
attaque je pense à l'allemagne où vous
souvenez d'attentats terrible madrid en
espagne
et puis multiples attentats en
grande-bretagne encore récents y compris
au couteau à l'armé blanche puisque
c'est le mode opératoire est pratiquée
en ce moment
alors oui la france peut être plus que
d'autres surtout actuellement est tout
simplement parce que la france n'a pas
le même rapport à la liberté la laïcité
d'ailleurs la laïcité française était
une quelque chose d'unique dans le monde
en grande bretagne il est l'intégration
qui n'est pas sous la forme de la
simulation sur l'intégration ou
communautariste les communautés vivent
côte à côte
chacune avec ses coutumes parfois on y
vit comme on vit dans le pays d'origine
alors ce n'est pas ce n'est pas la
france la france est un pays de la
civilisation la france est un pays de
liberté d'expression où je le rappelle
si ce n'est pas évident c'est pas
évident pour des anglo saxons
la religion est une opinion comme une
autre donc elle est critiquable elle est
et on peut blasphémer et c'est ça la
france et c'est quelque chose qui était
acquis de haute lutte contre contre le
catholicisme politique il n'ya aucune
raison d'être plus conciliants avec
l'islam politique et ceux qui ne peuvent
pas ne peuvent pas vivre dans un pays de
liberté et de liberté d'expression on
peut le faire en france pose une
question plutôt général est ce que le
principe de laïcité ça fonctionne bien
en france c'est à dire
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est un
principe qui est bien utilisé par les
politiques actuellement je sais pas
s'ils utilisent et s'il est bien utilisé
par l'ensemble des politiques mais
laïcité est au coeur de ce que la
république française
selon l'article 1er de la constitution
la république
la france est une république indivisible
social de et laïque et je crois que la
grande partie du pouvoir politique
français a à coeur de défendre la
laïcité qui est cette liberté
d'expression que nous chérissons la
liberté de l'expression là et qui est
également la garantie de culte mais dans
des limites privé ou dans les limites
des espaces religieux dédié et que la
religion n'a rien à faire dans l'espace
public et donc à part quelques quelques
plus que personnalité politique je crois
que dans son décor une politique
français et travail et un autre
c'est pour ça que me parce qu'on pas une
file et ils ne passeront pas mal malgré
la douleur malgré les morts malgré les
multiples attentats qui endeuillent
notre pays et paralyse considérablement
la vie la vie publique la vie
démocratique
in fine elles ne passeront pas novice je
vais vous demander de rebondir sur les
propos de monsieur b d'amis sur l'échec
de l'intégration et de l'assimilation
des étrangers en france est ce que c'est
un avis d'imposition vous partagez oui
enfin
d'abord le met face au terrorisme je
vous le disais la question d'immigration
peut poser problème c'est effectivement
le cas ici mais ce n'est pas la question
principale pour lutter contre le
terrorisme parce que c'est la question
qui était posée à monsieur bel ami je
répète c'est de renforcer le
renseignement intérieur et extérieur et
de renforcer la justice antiterroriste
ce qui ne peut pas se faire
non puisque nous avons des contraintes
budgétaires qui sont imposés par des
politiques voulues par l'union
européenne de restriction des budgets de
l'état et demande des policiers et des
gendarmes il manque des militaires voilà
c'est après un chose maintenant
effectivement sur l'intégration malate
et des rations par l'assignation qui
effectivement le moyen je le disais tout
à l'heure
d'intégrer en france mais fonctionne sur
un grand nombre d'immigrés la plupart
des immigrés de religion culture
musulmane sont intégrés en france on
voit très bien le sud est l'ami sait
très bien que madame rachida dati par
exemple et maire du 7e arrondissement
elle fait partie des îles me semble
assez dur et conservatisme conservatrice
des républicains
et il y a des gens qui s'intègrent
parfaitement partout dans toute la
société
il ya une minorité qui est mal
malheureusement croissante qui refuse la
simulation il faut bien comprendre que
les que les islamistes refusa sinisation
alors certes dans certains quartiers il
y à un manque de la public et un manque
d'écoles ya un manque de services
publics
il n'y a pas et il n'y a pas de travail
mais cela ne justifie pas l'islamisme
cela ne justifie pas les passages à
l'acte terroriste et je le répète ces
gens là refusent le coeur de ce qu'est
la république française refuse des
valeurs de la république française et
doivent être doivent quitter le
territoire national
ils refuseront s'assimiler ce sont des
combattants politiques qu'ils ont un
objectif politique
ils étaient sept objectifs politiques
est incompatible avec les valeurs de la
pluie français the do récuse masovic
gens peuvent être président de la
république souveraine merci d'avoir fait
ses débuts à nos questions monsieur